- Hi, I'm Bench Ansfeld,
and I'm graduating
from the Department of American
Studies with my doctorate.
I'm a historian of race
and capitalism with a focus
on US cities and cultural
studies of the built environment.
And I'm a 2021 winner of the
Field Prize for my dissertation
"Born in Flames: Arson, Racial Capitalism,
and the Reinsuring of the Bronx
in the Late Twentieth Century"
So Born in Flames examines
the wave of landlord arson
that coursed through the Bronx
and scores of other US
cities in the 1970s.
Though commonly confused with
the uprisings of the sixties,
these fires were lit, not
for protests, but for profit,
most of which float into
the ironically named
fire industries, that's finance,
insurance, and real estate.
It's by asking why cities went
up in flames in these years,
how the fires were extinguished,
and what arose in their ashes,
the project casts new light
on the restructuring of US
cities over the past five decades
and track how the turn
towards financialization
reached its peak right in the aftermath
of the civil rights movement's heyday
and asks what the coinciding nature
of those two formations can tell us
about this moment in the
history of race and capitalism.
At the center is the study
of a state subsidized
fire insurance program that was initiated
as a direct response to the
uprisings of the sixties.
Ostensibly intended to
end insurance redlining,
the program was more of a bailout
for the insurance industry
and it inadvertently
incentivized landlords
to set their buildings on fire.
Through a study of the Bronx,
known as the arson capital
of the world in these years,
I chronicle how Black and Latin X tenants
mobilized dozens of
anti arson organizations
that by the early 1980s stem
the tide of the burnings.
And then a final thread of
the project turns an eye
to the cultural responses to the buyers
by considering how the
ubiquity of the fire trope
in films, fiction, and popular music
of the era from "The Towering Inferno"
to "Disco Inferno" offers
a hidden transcript
for contested interpretations
of the arson wave.
These various threads
weave together a story
about risk, real estate,
and power in an era
with race and race thinking
were undergoing profound shifts.
Thanks.
- Hi, my name is Stefano Daniele
and I graduated in December, 2020
with a PhD from the
Department of Neuroscience.
My work focuses on global brain ischemia,
or in other words, how the brain responds
to interruptions in blood flow
such as in the case of cardiac arrest.
I'm a 2021 Porter Prize winner,
And my submission is entitled
"Ex Vivo Normothermic Restoration
of Circulation and Cellular Functions
in the Large Mammalian
Brain Hours Postmortem."
Now to place my PhD work in context,
traditional understanding
maintains that the brain
is highly vulnerable to
interruptions in blood flow,
tolerating only several minutes
of circulatory arrest
before undergoing widespread
and irreversible loss
of cellular viability.
However, over the past century,
multiple lines of observation have brought
into question the finality
of cellular viability
minutes or even hours after death
in the large mammalian brain.
Therefore, the central
question I asked in my PhD work
was how long after prolonged
global ischemia do cells
within the large mammalian
brain remain viable.
Now to test this question, my colleagues
and I developed a novel
technology called brain X
which consists of three components,
the first of which is a circulatory device
that is comprised of a variety
of membranes, pumps, and tubes
that mechanically mimic many
of the functions of the heart,
the lungs, and the kidney.
The second is a uniquely formulated
blood analog solution that is
entirely synthetic, acellular,
and it's supplemented with a cocktail
of protective agents to prevent cell death
and promote recovery from
prolonged periods of ischemia.
And the third is a surgical procedure
to isolate the brain from the skull,
allowing us to connect it
to the circulatory device.
Now utilizing this system,
my colleagues and I observed
that circulation and cellular
functions can be restored
in the large mammalian brain
up to four hours after death.
Now, these findings indicate that cells
in the large mammalian brain
retain a greater resilience
to lack of blood flow
than was once appreciated.
And importantly, these findings
may help lay the groundwork
for the development of novel therapies
to salvage brain tissue function
in patients suffering from
devastating conditions
such as cardiac arrest and stroke.
I thank you so much for your time,
and I thank the Porter Prize
Committee for this honor,
and I continue wishing you health
and safety during this difficult period.
Thank you again.
- My name is Zuri Sullivan.
and I earned my PhD in
immunobiology in December, 2020.
I'm fascinated by how the immune system
helps animals adapt to
different environments.
I am a 2021 winner of the Porter Prize,
and my prize submission was
entitled "Food Quality Control:
Nutrition and Immunity in
Intestinal Homeostasis."
The gastrointestinal tract is
a multi kingdom cellular ecosystem
that facilitates the procurement
of nutrients from the environment.
It is in constant contact
with the outside world
and is therefore simultaneously
a point of encounter
with life-threatening pathogens and toxins
and the site of absorption
for life sustaining nutrients.
Consequently, the intestine
is tasked with the challenge
of balancing its primary
functions of nutrient uptake,
bringing things in, with host
defense, keeping things out,
in response to a complex
and constantly changing environment.
This challenge is particularly
daunting for omnivores
like ourselves, whose diets
change on daily, seasonal,
and lifelong timescales
alongside encounters
with ingested toxins, enteric pathogens,
and trillions of commensal microbes.
Omnivorous lifestyles therefore require
that the GI tract be adaptable
to the dynamic nature of our environments.
My doctoral studies examined the cellular
and molecular mechanisms that
confer this adaptability.
Using mice as a model system,
I discovered that the machinery involved
in the digestion and
absorption of carbohydrates
was induced on demand in
response to a high carb diet.
This on-demand induction
involves changing the
cellular composition of
the intestinal epithelium,
demonstrating that the GI tract
can undergo rapid tissue remodeling
in response to different diets.
And my most surprising discovery
was that a specific type
of immune cell called gamma
delta T cells was required
for this intestinal
adaptation to carbohydrates.
This was the first demonstration
that an immune cell
can directly regulate nutrient
uptake in the intestine
and has established an
entirely new area of research
pertaining to the connection
between nutrition and immunity.
By linking nutrient
uptake and host defense
at the cellular and molecular levels,
these adaptations conferred
by the immune system
enable this complex tissue
to adjust the balance
between nutrient uptake and host defense
in response to environmental change.
Thank you very much
and congratulations to
all of the graduates.